[Music]
it's got to be a nice compliment for you
is that a lot of young people a lot of
fans of yours are dressing up as you as
one of your two characters and they've
got a choice they can either be Chloe
don't trust me right or they can be from
Breaking Bad I cannot believe that I am
two Halloween costumes that's gonna be
fun it's crazy so if I get lazy this
week I could just go with one of my
characters right on the show I've tried
going as myself on Halloween it doesn't
work it's really sad they think I'm a
ghost so pale no I'm Conan whatever you
any any costumes I know that usually
shows have a Halloween themed you know
wait are you gonna wear a costume on
that show we have four sexy costumes of
course I am a sexy bus driver no I mean
a sexy bus driver
it was just like low-cut and tight okay
okay I would say I you know like Ralph
Kramden
yeah like come on honey Motors
I was a sexy pair acute how do you do
that
you know tight again I was like 12 I
like a giant head and then the corset
and right all right right it worked
yeah well trust me I'm behind all of
this I think it's off wait the parakeet
had a corset yeah it would parakeet head
okay pretty much all you can say is I'm
[ __ ] Ben Franklin yeah no any
character yeah let's talk about your
character Chloe on don't trust the B
she's very sexually free the character
yeah but you yourself personally are get
squeamish even when you will oh I don't
like having to kiss strangers so when
they have an actor playing like a
handsome dude who's on the show and
you've got to kiss them that it makes
you squeamish no I don't like kissing
strangers I don't know where their
mouths have been I try to like do
something really sneaky I'll have like a
makeup artist slip them a mint or give
them a toothbrush after lunch and just
say it's protocol
it's so gross I mean that that's how you
get mouth herpes
kissing a bunch of strangers like they
that's how you get herpes simplex - I'm
sorry I don't want it you're making me
feel very differently about these sexy
scenes I just ruined everything
now I have noticed on the show you're
just about to kiss a guy and you're like
you know it's like so you you you you
have people go up to the guy whoever he
is do get any say over which guys you're
kissing yeah so that's the fun part so
since I have to like make out with so
many strangers they bring in
eight-by-tens of actors and then I just
go through and pick out all the ones
that look like male models and then I
have like a whole you know selection of
boys when it comes up they know who to
pick that's like you're like Cleopatra
Hey you're like bring me that one over
here sorry and then I've been doing this
stuff for years I'm enjoying it no I say
I'm not objecting at all all the guy
we're just all trying to figure out how
to get into the binder
put this good looking to God how did
American ginger get in there
because you one of your co-stars is
james van der beek and I love this
premise he plays himself yeah he plays
james van der beek on the show and
you're and and you're put you're talking
a lot about possibly having a Dawson's
Creek reunion
yeah is that something that it's a rumor
that's out there sometimes you guys have
toyed with that idea yeah it's a rumor
that's out there and I thought it was
just like crap I thought it wasn't true
right so everyone started asking about
it and so I had the idea that Katie
Holmes should come on and play my love
interest your Katie Holmes play your
love interest
wouldn't that be fabulous people I mean
everyone would tune in do you think
she'll do it maybe I think we look good
together she's also tall yeah yeah I
think everyone's saying yes they want to
see this happen I think we're getting a
general reaction of yes this would be
good but what do you think she would do
it I don't know I know as James would
have to probably call her up I better
call her quite influential in this town
don't trust the B in apartment 23 airs
Tuesday nights at 9:30 on ABC and I love
it when you come on the show thanks for
having me back are you kidding are you
talking about you're fantastic I'll
bring you presents I promise
yeah during the commercial break the
band was playing and you leaned over and
went what happens during this part I
like to let my audience here don't you
playing the bands playing and Kristin
leans over cause what happens during
this part I said this is the part where
you give Andy and I the presents you
brought us for a second year